[Music]
for 130 years visitors have made the
trip to the top of pikes peak in
colorado
on a train that's one of a kind now
after being closed for more than three
years and undergoing a 100 million
dollar renovation it's once again
bringing travelers on a breathtaking
journey
nancy chen went along for the ride
train 12 roger the high ball
out west all aboard for this age-old
expedition to timeless beauty where the
voyage itself
is the main attraction oh my goodness
uniquely equipped for its winding trek
through the rocky mountains
the world's highest and longest cog
railway
elevates visitors to soaring views it's
gorgeous from here
the broadmoor manitou in pike's peak cog
railway
is one of only two in the united states
and handles grades
as steep as 25 percent how high up
are we right now i can only guess we're
over 13
000 feet right now at full speed
conductor rod wilson clocks in
around 10 miles per hour and it's not
even steep yet wait for it the last hill
before the summit is the steepest one of
all of them so you gotta hold on tight
you might want to yes i'm in his chair
i'm good
between glimpses of the natural beauty
that inspired the song
america the beautiful and the wildlife
of bears and moose calling this land
home
bighorn sheep oh i see it the journey
can be an
hour long trip to the top
these are the panoramic views visitors
from around the world travel to sea
that's colorado springs down there where
the altitude is breathtaking
in every sense oh yeah it's harder to
get a deeper breath the campbell family
is visiting from memphis missouri
obviously when you come out west and
come to colorado springs it was
one of the destinations that you had to
see
as to how this 130 year old railway is
able to climb
to more than 14 thousand feet up
we went underneath the train with
assistant general manager
ted johnston what exactly is a cog
railway
so a cog railway we're a railway just
like any other railway but
we use a center third rail to get all
our traction and braking a typical
railway
they get all their traction and braking
through the outside rails
instead there's a center rail the cog
underneath the train hooks into
basically pulls the train up the
mountain
a groundbreaking system when it was
constructed in 1891
as saloons dominated the local landscape
against the backdrop of gold rush
fortunes
with the broadport and the cog railway
you really get a sense of what the old
wild west used to be like
absolutely we believe that the broadmoor
is kind of the
gateway to the american west the nearby
broadmoor hotel
owns the railway today president and ceo
jack demoli how did the idea for this
even come about
well there was a gentleman that was
staying at a motel in manitou springs
by the name of mr simmons he might have
made a mattress or two
beautyrest by simmons the do not disturb
mattress
yes that simmons zalman simmons was
also the inventor of the beautyrest
mattress his inspiration
a tedious two-day mule ride to the
summit
for a telegraph line inspection
passengers climbed aboard just
two years of construction later was it
innovative for its time
without a doubt and you think about 1891
and the fact that not too many railroads
were running in the united states period
let alone up america's mountain
as the years passed the trains
technology evolved with 20th century
innovation
the locomotives actually started with
wood fired
then went from wood fire to to steam
powered
and then from steam powered to
diesel-powered
in all the world there are only three
similar roads
but much of the railway's infrastructure
remained in place for more than 125
years
that was until 2018 when it shut down
for renovations
totaling more than a hundred million
dollars we looked at everything when we
did this project the track
the trains the depot facility that we're
at right now
and we retrofitted some of our older
equipment
the tracks were placed for the first
time since they were laid down
also new three trains and a snow blower
ready to tackle the hardiest of
conditions
as train transportation has modernized
cog railways are few and far between
including their parts their rarity
forced colorado engineers to look
overseas for help
in switzerland's stadler rail whose
trains traverse the alps
the teams working in tandem separated by
an ocean
and a pandemic so it was a very
interesting journey
they started on a truck from the styler
facility in busan switzerland
to basel switzerland where they were put
on a barge
to go up the rhine river to zebra
belgium
where they were put on a boat to go
across the atlantic
that seems like quite the journey it is
and it was very interesting to follow
all of it
one two and three there you are welcome
aboard
more than three years of renovations
later passengers boarded
the broadmoor manitou and pike's peak
cog railway
once again this summer
the experience of going to the summit of
a 14 000 foot mountain by rail has not
changed
yes the cars are new the track is new
but that awe-inspiring experience is all
the same
a timeless journey scaling new heights
for a new
generation for cbs this morning saturday
nancy chen
manitou springs colorado and nancy tells
us that train
runs all year all year round all year
round so in january you go up to the top
of pikes peak and it's five degrees
yeah be kind of a cool adventure uh why
not bundle up you can have a doughnut
we'll go
yeah right here is pretty good another
trip no
we're in we haven't taken one yet what
are we doing
we will one of these all right dealt
with some
interesting circumstances that's true
well hey next year